[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
daniel hablando en el estudio ya lista
para hablar de lo que ella ya dijo como
siempre adivinando lo que va a pasar en
esta vida y la otra que está comprando
en lomos tras el anuncio de que va a
adquirir en 100% la red social 'twitter'
daniela paola radón muy buenos días un
consejo cuando yo le diga algo créanme
bueno pero después le pregunto y le hago
una consulta personal a ver si va a ser
tan millonario como él bueno la manera
pues mire este acuerdo de compra primero
hay que decirlo todavía le faltan
autorizaciones regulatorias para
materializarse y lo segundo es que
implica para twitter dejar de ser una
compañía pública listada en bolsa para
ser propiedad de una sola persona en
términos de números llegamos a lo que me
gusta a mí de twitter es una red social
con más de 400 millones de usuarios pero
solamente la mitad son activos diarios
monetizables qué quiere decir esto que
son los que efectivamente ven los
anuncios
pero sus finanzas no atraviesan por el
mejor momento los ingresos en 2021
fueron de más de 5.000 millones de
dólares vienen creciendo año tras año
pero tiene pérdidas las pérdidas del año
pasado solamente alcanzaron los 221
millones de dólares en pleno año de
pandemia de hecho en 2020 registró más
de 1300 millones de dólares en pérdidas
y este jueves va a presentar los
resultados del primer trimestre ya los
veremos bueno a nivel que puede decirse
el precio pactado de su compra bueno
cuando llegamos el 14 de abril hizo
pública su oferta por poco más de 43 mil
millones de dólares en ese entonces dijo
que daría una muy buena prima sobre el
precio de cada acción en ese momento la
reacia junta directiva del entonces
finalmente accedió a esta oferta once
días después ahora veamos a comienzos de
mes el título de tweeter costaba poco
menos de 40 dólares en la bolsa de nueva
york cuando más que realizó la oferta ya
iba en 45 dólares y ahora se acerca a
los 52 dólares que es el precio que
finalmente él ofreció veremos también
cuánto va de aquí al final eso quiere
decir que la capitalización bursátil que
es el valor en bolsa de la compañía pasó
de 30 mil 100 millones de dólares el
primero de abril a cerca de 40 mil
millones en el más reciente cierre
cuando subió más del 5 por ciento que
fue el lunes desde que hizo el anuncio
la red social se ha valorizado unos 5
mil millones de nada - daniela bueno y
ahora pasamos a hablar de lo que podemos
hablar
del día
interesante ustedes sabéis quién es el
personaje con más seguidores en
'twitter' y la verdad no la verdad no lo
tengo en la mente pero puede ser un
líder político seguramente sí señor
barack obama con 131 siete millones de
seguidores le siguen justin bieber y
katy perry bueno ahí están los líderes
de twitter daniela ahora si pasamos a
hablar de ucrania las consecuencias de
la guerra sobre américa que está pasando
pero es que preparamos una serie que
vamos a estar emitiendo en el transcurso
de esta semana para ver algunos casos
específicos de países que están
sintiendo ese efecto de la invasión rusa
en los bolsillos tanto de las empresas
como de los ciudadanos comenzamos en el
ecuador cuyos enormes envíos de banano a
rusia cayeron drásticamente nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega visitó una
plantación y nos cuenta la historia
ecuador es el mayor productor de banano
del mundo
el país exporta 4 de cada 10 bananos
según cifras del banco central pero la
guerra entre rusia y ucrania amenaza el
negocio de los productores como franklin
torres la semana 9 que fue cuando se
produjo la guerra tuvimos precios de 6
dólares 625 que es el precio oficial de
la caja de banano el precio de la semana
10 bajó el 50 por ciento el precio de la
caja de banano
y hoy estamos vendiendo al 25% de la
caja
la reducción del valor del producto
también preocupa los recolectores martín
garcía dedicada hace 30 años a las
cimbras del banano siente amenazada su
estabilidad laboral en es por el banano
genera 300 mil empleos directos y un
millón indirectos se están reduciendo
personal porque no hay dinero para
cancelar no ya desde ya hay problemas no
nos cancelan por el problema del banano
porque no no hay dinero de tema
rusia ha sido un mercado estratégico
para el banano ecuatoriano en los
últimos 15 años según cifras de la
asociación de comercialización y
exportación de banano del ecuador de
2021 con corte a octubre uno de cada
diez bananos se exportó a rusia mientras
que la unión europea se destinó poco más
del 27 por ciento del total en su orden
otros grandes consumidores fueron el
medio oriente eeuu y europa del este
entre otros
de vuelta a los cultivos 585.000 cajas
de banano no pudieron salir de ecuador
desde febrero 2022 por falta de otros
mercados la devaluación del rublo ha
encarecido la exportación del banano y
la falta de pagos obliga a franklin a
buscar soluciones con un descuento a
nuestras liquidaciones de banano como se
lo hace el impuesto para que eso sirva
para este fondo de contingencia y con
ese fondo de contingencia poder de
alguna forma financiar lo que nosotros
queremos hacer el sector bananero
intenta buscar soluciones rápidas a esta
crisis simple vista para ello de mal
mente el gobierno y que las reglas de
exportación del banano crear los
registros de hectáreas sembradas en el
país según ellos inexistentes y
controlar la competencia desde al que
abarata los precios en medio del
conflicto
bueno y de esta manera dan y entonces
llegamos al final de nuestro primer
bloque de economía en directo américa
espero en el segundo bloque para
analizar lo que ha sido esta noticia del
día y también lo va a hacer por la
semana el pacto de compra de lomos con
twitter del año dan y gracias ya nos
vemos más adelante pasamos a ver nuestro
reportaje